SPEAKER_00: Theocoll engineers were concerned because cold could slow the O-rings at the exact moment they needed to seal.
SPEAKER_00: Their recommendation was clear.
SPEAKER_00: Do not launch below 53 degrees Fahrenheit.
SPEAKER_00: That number mattered because it was tied to the lowest relevant prior experience they believed they could defend.
SPEAKER_00: NASA managers pushed back.
SPEAKER_00: In a technical review, pushback can be necessary.
SPEAKER_00: The danger was the standard that began to govern the room.
SPEAKER_00: The question drifted.
SPEAKER_00: Show that this is safe to fly.
SPEAKER_00: Became prove that it will fail.
SPEAKER_00: That shift reversed the burden of proof.
SPEAKER_00: Instead of requiring evidence that launch was safe, the process demanded evidence that failure was certain.
SPEAKER_00: Engineering evidence usually does not arrive that way.
SPEAKER_00: It arrives as a missing margin, a condition outside experience, a trend with enough signal to matter before the catastrophe supplies certainty.
SPEAKER_00: The engineers had evidence of risk.
SPEAKER_00: They did not have an equation that converted temperature into guaranteed loss of vehicle.
SPEAKER_00: That absence became useful to the launch case.
SPEAKER_00: Theakol asked for an offline caucus.
SPEAKER_00: The caucus lasted far longer than the five minutes first requested.
SPEAKER_00: When they returned, the recommendation had changed.
SPEAKER_00: The new position was that the data was inconclusive and launch could proceed.
SPEAKER_00: The cold had not changed.
SPEAKER_00: The joint had not changed.
SPEAKER_00: The limits of the data had not changed.
SPEAKER_00: The decision frame changed.
SPEAKER_00: One instruction from that caucus still carries the shape of the moment.
SPEAKER_00: Jerry Mason told Bob Lund to take off his engineering hat and put on his management hat.
SPEAKER_00: No single phrase explains the disaster.
SPEAKER_00: No single person explains it either.
SPEAKER_00: The deeper fact is that the same process could take a specific engineering objection and return a launch recommendation from the same evidence.
SPEAKER_00: The launch eve reversal is dramatic, but it is not the whole failure.
SPEAKER_00: A warning also has to travel.
SPEAKER_00: It has to move from hardware to engineers, from engineers to managers, from contractors to NASA, from lower review levels to the people with authority to stop the launch.
SPEAKER_00: At each step, the signal can be compressed.
SPEAKER_00: Compression is normal in large programs, but when compression changes an active objection into a resolved item, the system has made a decision without naming it directly.